[Music]
so you are waiting on The Witcher 3 yeah
man me too well as we all know patience
is a mark of low births so we can't just
wait around
fortunately same fiction that gave rise
to this game we're all eager to play has
also borne fruit in other media so we
can dive into the witcher before we dive
into the witcher no what you don't
believe me well I've got a list to prove
it to you number 5 imagine a video game
that you couldn't play that's a movie
imagine a movie that just hopped from
frame to frame that's a comic book and
comic books are awesome
and there are Witcher comic books Dark
Horse has published one complete story
arc in five issues called House of glass
and has another one in progress called
Fox children in house of glass Geralt
meets a grieving hunter in the woods
with a secret and talks about whether
witches can truly love with a woman with
a secret and finds himself in a creepy
old house with a buttload of secrets in
Fox Children Geralt buys booze from a
troll and then takes passage on a ship
with his dwarf buddy when he finds out
what the other folks on the ship are up
to he wants none of it but it's too late
and they're in a tight spot you can pick
up the entirety of House of glass in a
single volume while Fox children's first
two issues are out now with the third
due out next month these are all
available in physical or digital format
because we live in the future now number
four everything is a board game these
days and The Witcher is no exception in
The Witcher adventure game you build
structures out of cards and tiny
tombstones and try to knock over popular
characters from The Witcher with the
disks of power until you get bored and
then actually read the rules place hero
figure on the board starting class two
cars in the quest Tech one unfolds then
is a series of intertwining adventures
as you compete against up to three other
people to complete three main quests out
of a big deck of diplomatic combative or
magical options you might try to recover
some royal jewels that a princess gave
to her foreign lover or seek out a rat
king that has been rumored to be
abducting drunks and orphans to do so
you'll need to travel the board picking
up leads and weathering fair and foul
fortune while using your characters
unique toolset to
the best of your ability success wah-wah
and if you don't have any friends nearby
to play it with there's also a digital
version of the game on Steam much harder
to lose digital game pieces I'm just
saying number three you guys ever seen a
YouTube video of adults torturing a kid
in a cave do you want to then look no
further than the edge Mena the Polish TV
series from 2002 that chronicles a
number of the witcher's adventures
including how he came to be a Witcher
through old man cave torture the whole
13 episode series is up on YouTube with
handy English subtitles for those of
everyone who doesn't understand Polish
and it's got everything sword fights CG
dragons a green lady talking CD dragons
Jennifer John T hats beards that grow
over time adult situations and
everybody's favorite every horse ever
Roche have I watched every episode of V
H mean no can I recommend the edge meet
no is V edge mean the only entry on this
list that is free yes number two have
you ever thought gee it'll be really
cool than know stuff about The Witcher
of course you have your watching this
video aren't you but still check out
this book I mean really check this out
it's called the world of Witcher and
damn if it ain't classy it's got the
built-in bookmark ribbon the silvery
edges and so many words inside and
pictures oh such pictures okay for a
real though this book is stacked it
describes all the realms of the
witcher's world and the races that
populate it it illuminates what witchers
are and how they came to be that way
there are pages and pages on magics and
religions and horrible beasties and the
story of The Witcher himself Geralt of
Rivia and all 180 ish pages are
liberally highlighted with gorgeous art
it's a beauty and if you want to get
real decadent about it there's a limited
edition that comes in this boss case
with an extra print and six pins that
you can pin to stuff but not do magic
with
at least as far as I know you can get
just the book in physical or digital
format from Amazon or get the super
Swank edition from jinx number one if
you want the good stuff you got to go
right to the source so pick up a Polish
language learning program raise your
fluency to an eighth grade reading level
and experience The Witcher series in all
its sub guff ski tacular glory there are
plenty of great resources available
online chest yes the jnana and just
think of all the Polish speaking country
you'll be able to visit once you're
fluent this method will teach you about
a rich and fascinating culture and help
you grow as a true citizen of the world
or you could just say [ __ ] it and read
the English translation for Witcher
novels are available now in English with
a 5th on the way in physical or digital
copies these are the works that started
at all folks so what better way to
prepare your body mind and soul for the
arrival of The Witcher 3 na beats old
man cave torture any day